[Music]
why do you think the song has resonated
with so many people everybody has had
that experience of really wanting to do
something and being afraid I think
everybody who is there working on the
song like has that sort of spirits just
kind of not being an option to give up
that's partly what inspired Teddy Geiger
and Shawn Mendes to write in my blood
their latest smash hit the best stuff we
do comes from having like conversations
and just like hanging out his friends
and I think the thing that really makes
it great is Shawn being truthful about
how he feels and what he's going through
what was it like when you guys found out
that the songs been nominated for a
Grammy Teddy Geiger Scott Harris Shawn
Mendes I was in shock just cause like I
don't know I've never been nominated for
a Grammy before while working with
Mendes on this album in 2017 Giger
decided she was ready to come out
publicly as transgender what did Shawn
say when you decided to do this
he was just super supportive I felt like
accepted and loved growing up in
Rochester New York Geiger was drawn to
music at a young age learning gets hard
in piano writing songs with friends and
recording demos in the basement
Geiger hit full-blown teen heartthrob
status in the mid-2000s with her single
for you I will but she started feeling
like a pop star product and had long
struggled with her gender identity
people have their image of you or their
ideas about who you are and it can be
frustrating when you saw yourself on
magazine covers did you think that that
was really you you know a lot of times
I'd be startled and like wearing a
t-shirt I wouldn't ever wear her all the
sudden there's this image of you and
you're like hold on wait at 21
Geiger stepped away from teen stardom
she established a career as one of the
most sought-after songwriters in the
industry writing for artists like one
direction and James Blunt but while
Geiger gained
a petition as a studio virtuoso she also
developed anxiety and a dependence on
cigarettes and marijuana I wasn't
sleeping I wasn't eating that great and
it would just be like from the time I
woke up till the time I went to bed
Geiger went to treatment for
obsessive-compulsive disorder it was
there she confronted her truth that she
is transgender when I was growing up I
didn't know of anybody who was trends
there was always this like shame anxiety
thing around all of that even if I
wasn't actively like expressing it
there had been moments when she did
express her femininity on the advice of
an ex-girlfriend painting my nails was
one of the things I like to do and I was
so terrified of like ever letting
anybody see my nails painted she was
like well who cares just paint you know
so I started just painting my nails and
going out Geiger says the urge to smoke
and her OCD tendencies went away within
a week after coming out to those closest
to her so I told a couple friends about
it I was like hey might be trans might
want to like look at doing hormone
therapy just letting you know and they
were like yeah cool like who cares
like whatever also Geiger is one of
three trans women to receive Grammy
nominations this year a win would be
historic it's cool for people to be able
to see that and to have more artists and
people who are trans just like doing
things and kind of being invisible in
November Geiger released her first solo
album since transitioning Lilliana named
for the online pseudonym she used in her
younger years the album a collection of
songs Geiger wrote over the course of
eight years explores identity
self-expression and the freedom
she's found so when you look in the
mirror now it's clear what do you see
myself not always 100% happy with it you
know but I'm like I still psyched